qu internet s'installe dans le monde du
travail et en particulier dans celui des
patrons les internautes et les chefs
d'entreprise dialogue à travers ces
femmes blog sorte de journaux
interactive david bory figeac et nicolas
23 ans tout juste diplômé d'une école de
commerce il a rendez vous pour un
entretien d'embauché bien merci d'être
venus ils se voient pour la première
fois mais leur rencontre a en fait
commencé il ya quelques semaines sur
internet car nicolas a créé ce qu'on
appelle un blog un carnet de notes
électroniques personnels libre d'accès
et publiée sur le net principe du blog
c'est qu'on peut interagir sait bien que
quand quelqu'un écrit quelque chose on
peut faire un commentaire il répondait
en fait ça démarre une discussion une
discussion directe et rapide et sans
intermédiaire chasseurs de têtes ce chef
d'entreprise a lui aussi son blog
au départ c'était juste quelques pages
de conseils mais rapidement le blog est
devenu un nouvel outil très utile pour
le recrutement
globalement les faits blog c'est un
investissement d'une heure par jour
me permet d'augmenter ma visibilité donc
j'ai plus de candidats environ 30%
c'est à peu près la mesure que l'on a
est également des nouveaux clients il y
aurait aujourd'hui près de 12 millions
de blogs dans le monde des particuliers
qui sont aussi des clients ou des
consommateurs un phénomène qui intéresse
de plus en plus de chefs d'entreprises
pour un patron c'est une manière de se
rapprocher de ses clients et donc
effectivement conditions déjà quand ils
écrivent déjà sur internet c'est déjà
une manière de l'est de reconnaître
qu'un dialogue peut s'instaurer
mais cela peut aussi être une menace
exemple avec un fabricant dans six vols
pour vélos aux états unis cette vidéo
diffusée en septembre dernier sur un
blog montre comment le forcer avec un
simple stylo bille en moins d'une
semaine près de 2 millions d'internautes
l'avaient vu et l'entreprise a dû le
retirer de la vente manque à gagner 10
millions de dollars